destination de ces familles dont la vie
a été bouleversée merci la parole est à
monsieur laurent furent
monsieur le premier ministre parce que
je suis député et maire je prépare
actuellement le budget de notre commune
je dois vous dire qu'après quatre ans de
baisse de dotation et de hausse
permanente des contraintes des nouveaux
rythmes scolaires jusqu'au carte
d'identité demain c'est un véritable
waterloo budgétaire que vous imposer aux
maires de france
l'autre jour le maire d'un village de ma
circoncision m'a dit tous ces efforts je
les accepterai si au moins cela servait
à quelque chose si cela faisait baisser
la dette et c'est là monsieur le premier
ministre que j'ai lu un article de
presse puis consulté la loi de finances
qui rappelle un certain nombre de choses
votre gouvernement composé de manière
très politicienne pour atomiser les
verts comptent 38 ministres ce qui
constitue un record depuis dix ans cela
suppose des agents de sécurité des
chauffeurs des millions d'euros et cela
suppose à chaque fois à cabinets
ministériels
depuis votre arrivée à matignon les
effectifs des cabinets ont bondi de 22%
et les engagements pris par le président
de la république de limiter à 10
personnes par secrétaire d'état et par
quinze 15 personnes par ministre n'a
jamais été aussi peu tenu et puis il ya
les salaires 7624 euros brut en moyenne
dix mille deux cent quarante six pour
matignon avouez que cela est plutôt
confortable au total en deux ans la
hausse des dépenses pour les cabinets
aura été de 12% monsieur le premier
ministre vous étranglez budgétairement
les communes de france est parallèlement
quand il s'agit de l'élite rose les
dépenses flambent l'argent coule à flots
à l'heure où les maires de france essaye
de boucler leurs budgets souvent avec
infiniment de difficultés n'avez vous
pas monsieur le premier ministre
sentiment que votre gouvernement donne
un bien mauvais exemple en matière de
gestion d'argent public
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
monsieur le député mois d'un mot
seulement parce que ces débats vous les
avez dans le cadre des discussions des
débats d'un mot et je vous donne mon
sentiment sec et bref j'en ai assez de
tous ceux qui dans la vie politique met
en cause en permanence oui les élus
locaux oui les parlementaires où il est
membre des gouvernements oui les membres
des cabinets ministériels
continuons ainsi
épousons le populisme mettons en cause
des institutions mettons cause en
permanence le président la république le
gouvernement le parlement les corps
intermédiaires les élus les syndicats la
vie associative continuons ainsi et nous
serons balayés balayé par le populiste
parce que vous trouverez toujours
davantage ceux et celles en france et
ailleurs qui mettront en cause le pilier
les fondements de la république je sais
monsieur le député qu'il faut évidemment
changé réforme et transformer la vie
politique comme l'action gouvernementale
je le sais souvent que la vie politique
est devenu langue morte mais je sais
aussi que sans la démocratie
représentative
sans le parlement sans les élus sans les
bénévoles sans ce qui fait la sève du
pays notre pays la république la france
ne seront pas et si j'ai dans ma vie
quelque chose à dire aux français et
donc à vous mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires c'est qu'il faut se
battre pour ça pour cette démocratie
pourcel république pour ce parlement et
pour les élus aient jamais jamais
sombrer dans le populisme dans le
discours contre les îles les élus dans
le disco contre les élus dans le
discours de ce qui représente
profondément la france c'est ça la
démocratie
faites attention à ces discours qui
peuvent tous balayés demain
[Applaudissements]